Genetics show defects in my Tp53 genes, and I'm more susceptible for other cancers.
So your Tp53 genes, or commonly known as the P53 genes, are the most researched
tumor spressor genes.
There was one of the first tumor spressor genes discovered.
There have been books written on the P53 genes, what they do.
There's been a lot of research over the years on the P53 genes.
There are tumor spressor genes, remember, tumor spressor genes are genes inside every cell
that will turn on if the cell goes into rapid replication and stimulate a capsaic reaction
that causes intrinsic apoptotic pathway progression and causes the cell to go through
apoptosis.
In short, there are genes that turn on if cancer starts to kill the cancer.
Kills the cancer from the inside out, kills the cell from the inside out.
If I have defects on tumor spressor genes, then it can hinder that intrinsic pathway.
So it hinders the killing of the cancer, so the cancer continues to progress unabated.
You can only have extrinsic, or you have less intrinsic, so inside the cell sources,
and you're relying more on extrinsic outside the cell, ways to kill the cancer.
For instance, you're doing things to stimulate your immune system to help kill the cancer.
You're using the right to help kill the cancer, you're using chemotherapy to help kill cancer.
Those are all extrinsic pathways of apoptosis.
You're stimulating extrinsic pathways of apoptosis with chemotherapy, you might be trying to stimulate
lysis, not necessarily apoptosis, but pathological death in the cell.
So when you have defects on tumor spressor genes, that's not good, right?
So let's say a breast cancer and a defects on the T53 genes, and that's at least partly
the reason why my cancer has progressed to a diagnosis, and now I'm working on extrinsic
and intrinsically trying to stimulate P53, and one of the great things to do to help stimulate
the fact that P53 is to take curcumin, that's one of the interventions for the P53 gene defects.
So even if you don't have defects on P53, and you're taking curcumin, it's helping stimulate
that intrinsic pathway of destruction.
So, but am I susceptible to other cancers?
Yeah, yeah, you are, yes.
That's why I would be good to run your genetics, somebody who doesn't have cancer.
Well, if I read by genetics, before I got cancer, and I phoned out, I had P53 gene defects,
and I started interventions, like taking curcumin, when I have prevented cancer, maybe,
maybe, yeah, which you can also say if I ate better, and I was, you know, understood that
toxins caused cancer, and I ran toxicity test before this, and I dealt with those things
when I have prevented my cancer.
Yeah, maybe, that's, that's, that's all true.
So the more things you, that's true, that's real prevention, you know, whereas the medic
professor goes, you should run early cancer screening, you know, that's preventative medicine
is early screening.
No, it's not, it's just early detection, it doesn't prevent anything.
So true prevention is to look at the things that cause a disease and address those before
the disease exists.
So it would be to run toxicity tests before you have cancer, to run a genetic profile,
before you have cancer, and deal with those things.
Well, there's a lot of other things genetically that you could look at other than just cancer,
but, you know, you could look at, well, once by susceptibility to Alzheimer's, we could
run a genetic profile and see where my susceptibility is.
You could run a blood test on the Alzheimer pathways and see what my susceptibility is.
So there's different things that you can do.
That's what preventative medicine is.
And then making lifestyle changes in the hopes to prevent or to push out that disease.
So still I get it, but I might get it by 90s instead of in by 60s.
So that's, that's true preventative medicine.
So yes, if my genetics showed defects in my TP53 genes, am I more susceptible to other
cancers?
Yes, yes, you are.
So that's why you continue doing the right thing, even if we've knocked out the cancer,
we continue to do the right thing.